my name is Philip tan I
research scientists here at the MIT game
lab and I've been teaching various game
crosses here in MIT for about ten years
every night i play starcraft for a
couple of games just to help me calm
down and get to sleep so that's kind of
my regular ritual otherwise I've lately
picked up this game called desert
golfing which is just kind of endless
golfing on the iPhone and it's strangely
soothing yet maddening at the same time
right now I'm actually working with a
blizzard entertainment to try to create
different ways for players to fall poor
people who are interested in StarCraft
to spectate a game being played by
professionals so we're about fixing
I'm really looking forward to what the
students that are making I they usually
impress me with some sort of like far
out of left field approach to the
problems that we put forward to them and
this year what kind of ramping up the
design challenge so I'm interested to
see where to go with that
class i'm pretty much focused mostly on
my four-year-old kid and relearning what
fun is actually through her eyes
I'd like to see a lot more different
kinds of games about a whole bunch of
different things right now I feel were
right at the cusp of you know like a
Cambrian explosion of different ideas
tools are out there the knowledge is
getting out there this idea than anyone
can make a game but I feel that there
are still a lot of sort of social and
systemic barriers to prevent people from
getting every idea in into distribution
so we're still kind of constrained to a
small set of genres familiar genres that
we see a lot of those games I'd like to
get a greater variety out there